[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont l'athlétisme commence décidément
très bien pour les français si les
choses vont aussi bien pour eux l'an
prochain à Tokyo il reviendront sûrement
à Paris après avoir plané quelques
médailles olympiques mais nous n'en
sommes pas encore là pour le moment
c'est alors performance actuelle que
nous nous intéressons et à celle de
Robert boget à Moscou en particulier de
Sare numéro 7 il pulvérise le record de
France du 10000 mètres de plus de 13
secondes et par surcroît il coiffe le
soviétique Ivanov sur le fil et cela
aussi c'est une performance
quant à Michel JAZY c'est également
Moscou qu'il a choisi pour ses premiers
grands débuts internationaux sur 5000
mètres
après un début de course extrêmement
prudent Michel JAZY attend le dernier
400 mètres pour démarrer comme les seuls
au monde c'est le faire résultat une
nouvelle victoire et un nouveau record
de France du 5000 mètres
[Musique]
si la visite du général de Gaulle a
bonne s'inscrite aujourd'hui dans la
routine des relations franco-allemandes
elle n'en prend pas moins après la
visite de Monsieur Kennedy une
signification de confiance dans les
destinées du traité récemment ratifié
[Musique]
le chancelier de Noël et ses ministres
au premier plan desquels le futur
chancelier monsieur Herard tonnette avec
Monsieur Pompidou et les 5 ministres qui
l'accompagnaient une première séance de
travail qu'on peut presque considérer
comme une séance commune des cabinets
allemands et français déjà un premier
pas a été fait avec la signature d'un
accord qui prévoit des échanges de la
jeunesse des deux pays
à Berla Hestre monsieur kotchafa rendu
visite au président de la République
démocratique allemande monsieur
valteroul en même temps que les leaders
des gouvernements de tchécoslovaques
polonais hongrois et bulgare prétexte
les 70 ans de valteroul Bridge en
réalité réunion au sommet des états
d'obédiance communiste seul manquait à
la Réunion le chef du gouvernement
roumain en froid avec l'URSS décoration
et festivités ne voilent donc qu'un
parfaitement la signification politique
de cette rencontre
[Musique]
nous devons cette année une pensée
particulière à un Français Adolf pegout
pegout fut en quelque sorte un pilote
d'essai des temps héroïques c'est ainsi
qu'il avait expérimenté un système
d'accrochage des avions pour le
décollage et la pontage susceptibles
d'être par la suite utilisé sur les
cuirasses
peggout effectua de la sorte une série
concluante d'un vol et d'accrochage sur
un film
[Musique]
de telles exercices auraient suffis à
lui mériter sa réputation d'un trépidité
mais il fit plus un jour de 1913 il
décola à bord d'un monoplan Blériot pour
exécuter devant une foule médusée les
premiers loopings qui est jamais été
tentés en exploit qui compte tenu de
l'époque Vallès sans doute tous les
exploits accomplis depuis
[Musique]
c'est aussi celui des fourmis géantes
domaine inquiétant que la Colombie
partage avec ses voisins d'Amérique du
Sud
mais la vie tout entière est ailleurs et
essentiellement dans les villes bâtit
tantôt comme Bogota à 2600 mètres dans
la cordillère tantôt au fond des vallées
du passé espagnol la capitale de la
Colombie n'a gardé que quelques rares
balcons quelques églises
[Musique]
c'est pratiquement une ville nouvelle
dont le développement intensif ne cesse
pas elle compte un million 300 000
habitants aujourd'hui pour une nation de
15 millions
[Musique]
et la longueur de la file desireurs
donne la mesure du grouillement de la
cité
celle-ci s'en orgueille de posséder un
aéroport international qui a la
réputation d'être le plus moderne de
l'Amérique latine
[Musique]
le café à sa propre banque à Bogota
banco qui a fait terreau c'est qu'il est
une des premières ressources de ce pays
deuxième producteur du monde en valeur
absolue la Colombie et le premier
producteur de café de type léger
la Banque Nationale évoque un autre
record la Colombie et le premier
producteur mondial d'émeraude c'est dans
son sol qu'on a découvert les plus
grosses de ces pierres aussi appréciées
que les diamants
nedeline est une ville de vallée ici au
cours des 50 dernières années les
statues précolombiennes ont vu une
humble bourgade devenir une ville de 650
000 habitants c'est la ville
industrielle de la Colombie 21% de la
production du pays sortent de ces
manufactures
pour s'industrialiser la Colombie à
disposer sur place de cette source
d'énergie par excellence qu'est le
pétrole pays de l'Eure c'est aussi le
pays de l'or noir que les pompes achève
d'aspirer dans les puits les plus
anciens 8 millions de tonnes par an dont
près de la moitié est absorbé par la
consommation nationale des raffineries
ont poussé au bord de la Magdalena le
grand axe fluvial qui traverse la
Colombie du sud au nord
à l'embouchure du fleuve dans la mer des
Antilles où la température moyenne
atteint 30 degrés barankia monopolise le
commerce colombien vers l'Europe
[Musique]
ici commence un autre pays avec ses
cactus scandellabre et son climat
méditerranéen la Côte d'Azur de la
Colombie en quelque sorte la plage de
Santa Marta évoque ses paradises
enchanteurs de vacances qui à l'heure du
ski nautique ressemble tous à la Floride
[Musique]
qui par cette côte où les Espagnols
fondèrent la Cartagène des Indes car
hiver tous les envahisseurs et ils
furent nombreux si bien que le plus
éloquent symbole de la cité et cette
statue d'un héros national privé d'une
jambe d'un drap d'un œil
de la tortue n'est pas loin et
Carthagène a subi en attendant celui des
touristes l'assaut quasi permanent des
corsaires les Anglais Grecs et Morgan le
français pointe
mais on n'a pas de rancune à Carthagène
la flibuste fait toujours recette
[Musique]